nadie desea construir un intervalo de
confianza para estimar la media del
rango de manejo del nuevo vehículo
eléctrico de su compañía ella requiere
un margen de error que no sobrepase los
10 kilómetros con un nivel de confianza
del 90% un estudio piloto sugiere que
para este tipo de vehículo el rango de
manejo tiene una desviación estándar de
15 kilómetros cuál de los siguientes es
el tamaño mínimo de la muestra
aproximado necesario para obtener el
margen de error requerido pausa el vídeo
y ver si puedes resolver el problema la
forma tradicional de construir un
intervalo de confianza consiste en tomar
una muestra para la cual se le calcula
la media y después le sumamos o le
restamos un margen de error alrededor de
la media así es cómo obtenemos el ínter
de confianza y la manera en la que hemos
calculado el margen de error para la
media ha sido de la siguiente manera si
no conocemos la desviación estándar de
la población dar un estadístico t el
cual le ponemos el nombre de t estrella
este es nuestro valor crítico y a él lo
multiplicamos por la desviación estándar
de la muestra dividido esto a su vez
entre la raíz cuadrada de n por la raíz
cuadrada del tamaño de la muestra ahora
la pregunta que se plantea es cuál es el
tamaño de muestra apropiado dado que
queremos tener un nivel de confianza del
90% y lo peculiar en este caso es que
para usar una tabla tema que necesitamos
aquí no solo necesitamos conocer el 90%
del nivel de confianza también
necesitamos los grados de libertad y si
recuerdas los grados de libertad se dan
por n menos 1
pero no podemos calcular esto si no
tenemos n como determinamos entonces a n
por otra parte tampoco conocemos la
desviación estándar de la muestra hasta
que no tomemos algunas muestras entonces
en lugar de todo esto lo que podemos
hacer es considerar otra manera adecuada
de construir un intervalo de confianza
con todo y su margen de error ahora a
partir de otra vez de la media de la
muestra ya esto también le vamos a sumar
y restar un valor z un valor crítico
para el cual ahora usaremos la tabla
zeta entonces pondremos z estrella ya
esto lo vamos a multiplicar por el valor
real de la desviación estándar
poblacional y esto a su vez dividido
entre la raíz cuadrada de
y tal vez podrías objetar oye no
conocemos la desviación estándar
poblacional sin embargo nos dicen que un
estudio piloto sugiere que para este
tipo de vehículo el rango de manejo
tiene una desviación estándar de 15
kilómetros entonces podemos usar este
valor como un estimado de la desviación
estándar poblacional y por lo tanto esto
de aquí es 15 kilómetros por otra parte
lo bueno de la tabla zeta es que no
requieres grados de libertad así que
solamente necesitamos saber este 90% de
confianza y ahora lo importante de todo
esto es que queremos que esta parte de
aquí es decir el margen de error sea
menor o igual a 10 kilómetros porque es
justo lo que nos dice el problema ella
requiere un margen de error que no
sobrepase los 10 kilómetros
puedo escribir ahora que z estrella esto
que multiplica a su vez a 15 y dividido
entre la raíz cuadrada de n esto tiene
que ser menor o igual a 10 kilómetros y
ahora podemos establecer cuál es el
valor de estas theta estrella para un
nivel de confianza del 90% y entonces
despejar a n así que hagamos eso ahora
para encontrar hace está estrella podría
utilizar mi tabla zeta como lo hemos
venido haciendo en los vídeos pasados
sin embargo para variar la metodología
ahora usaremos una calculadora entonces
voy a traer mi calculadora y ahora para
encontrar el valor de z estrella
correspondiente al nivel de confianza
del 90% usaremos una función llamada
inversa normal
puedes ver que es la opción 3 y la vamos
a seleccionar lo que tenemos que hacer
ahora es dar el valor del área bajo
normal inclusive puedes especificar la
media y la desviación estándar aunque en
este caso queremos la media igual a 0 y
la desviación estándar igual a 1 para
determinar el puntaje z solamente lo que
hace la función es darte el puntaje z
para el área correspondiente deseamos y
de hecho ya está la opción seleccionada
un área central del 90% así que
tecleamos aquí punto 9 recuerdan 90% en
el centro requiere 5% en cada cola así
que en lugar de usar el 0.9 en el centro
podría haber usado el 0.05 con la opción
de o la izquierda o con la opción de con
la derecha pero esto es exactamente lo
que queremos así que déjame pegar la
función y esto deberá proporcionarnos el
valor z adecuado y aquí lo tenemos si
quiero el 90% central es decir el área
central que sea el 90% entonces debería
incluir aproximadamente 1.600
35 desviaciones estándar por debajo de
la media y la misma cantidad por arriba
de la media así que nuestro valor
crítico corresponde a aproximadamente
1.600 45 déjame escribirlo ahora ya sé
que este valor crítico es 1.645 es justo
lo que obtuve con la calculadora y de
aquí me quedan que 1.645 esto que a su
vez multiplica a 15 y esto a su vez
dividido entre la raíz cuadrada de n
esto debe de ser menor o igual a 10
ahora hay un par de formas para resolver
esto que tengo aquí y encontrar la
respuesta podemos hacer algo de álgebra
para resolver esta desigualdad es más te
invito a que lo hagas o podemos probar
estos valores en la desigualdad para
verificar cuáles de ellos hacen
cumple y ya que tengamos todos elegir el
menor sin embargo voy a hacerlo de la
manera algebraica pues si nadie tiene
este problema en la vida real no va a
poder contar con varias opciones para su
solución necesitará calcular el tamaño
de la muestra para realizar su estudio
entonces hagamos esto si divido de ambos
lados de esta desigualdad entre 1.645 y
entre 15 que obtengo bueno voy a obtener
lo siguiente 1 entre la raíz cuadrada de
n
esto va a ser menor o igual a 10 que a
su vez está dividido entre 1.600 45 y
éste está multiplicado por 15 tomando el
recíproco de ambos lados voy a obtener
que la raíz cuadrada de n
esto va a ser mayor o igual recuerda al
tomar el recíproco de ambos lados se
invierte el signo de la desigualdad y
del lado derecho obtengo 1.645 esto
multiplicado por 15 y todo esto dividido
entre 10 ahora 15 / 10 esto es lo mismo
que 1.5 entonces me queda 1.645 por 1.5
y se ahora elevó de ambos lados al
cuadrado entonces ahora si voy a tener
que n va a ser mayor o igual a bueno
1.645 que multiplican a 1.5 y todo esto
a su vez está elevado al cuadrado
ahora saquemos de nuevo la calculadora
para elevar esto al cuadrado
bueno 1.645 por 1.5 esto elevado al
cuadrado obtenemos aproximadamente 6.109
así que n tiene que ser mayor que 6.09 n
tiene que ser mayor o igual que 6.09
pero como el tamaño de la muestra por
supuesto tiene que ser un número entero
cuál es el menor de los enteros que es
mayor que 6.09 bueno es este 7 de aquí
por lo tanto esta es mi opción correcta
este es aproximadamente el tamaño de la
muestra mínimo necesario para obtener el
margen de error requerido por supuesto
no tenemos la certeza de esto hasta que
nos llevemos a cabo el estudio
aquí estamos usando un estimado de la
desviación estándar poblacional y usamos
una tabla zeta
para
resolver este problema va a ser
interesante verificar cuando nadie haga
el estudio si en realidad obtiene un
margen de error no mayor a 10 kilómetros
con un nivel de confianza del 90% nos
vemos en el próximo vídeo